madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs jamais votre assemblée nora
dans cette histoire récente examiné en
aussi peu de temps autant de textes
électoraux loi organique du 24 décembre
2001 relative au délai d'organisation
des élections législatives et
sénatoriales partielles loi portant
report du renouvellement général des
conseils départementaux et des conseils
régionaux que vous venez d'adopter
définitivement
et ce soir cet après midi le projet de
loi organique relatif à l'élection du
président de la république
les deux textes de report devait gérer
l'immédiat l'urgence de concilier
impératifs démocratique est impératif
sanitaire
vous les avez examiné dans un esprit
foncièrement républicain dans un esprit
de rassemblement de responsabilités au
moment où notre pays reste confronté à
une crise sanitaire sans précédent
le projet de loi organique que vous
examinez ce soir nous invite pour sa
part à renouer avec une forme de entre
guillemets normalité démocratique tout
en nous projetant résolument dans
l'avenir renouer d'abord en procédant
comme chaque année qui précède
l'élection présidentielle à
l'actualisation de la loi organique du 6
novembre 1962 pour rendre applicable au
scrutin présidentiel les évolutions des
règles du code électoral intervenues
depuis à la dernière élection
il permet aussi comme à chaque fois de
tenir compte des remarques formulées par
le conseil constitutionnel
à l'occasion du dernier scrutin ces
adaptations allons d'ailleurs étaient
examinés par votre commission des lois
et ne pose pas le sujet de principe
puisqu'elle s'en tiennent pour
l'essentiel à l'application du droit
commun c'est ce souhait de s'en tenir au
droit commun qui explique d'ailleurs que
le gouvernement ait défendu au cours de
l'examen parlementaire de ce texte le
fait d'écarter le recours à la double
procuration par exemple qui ne se
justifiait dans son esprit qu'en cas de
circonstances exceptionnelles ou le
maintien de la durée d'un an de la
campagne présidentielle nous
andrew lors des débats un texte
classique un rendez vous traditionnel
donc solidement ancrées dans notre
tradition républicaine
mais pourtant il s'agit aussi je le
crois d'un texte qui nous invite
collectivement à nous projeter à nous
projeter par delà la crise sanitaire qui
devrait le vaccin est d'en être derrière
nous en 2022 nous l'espérons tous pour
envisager et plus largement la question
des modalités de vote dans notre pays
car l'objectif du gouvernement face à ce
que certains experts qualifient parfois
de désenchantement démocratique
c'est bien de créer les conditions de la
participation la plus large possible des
citoyens français aux élections la
participation la plus large possible
c'est d'abord assurer l'accessibilité du
vote à tous nos constituent à nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap
vous savez combien le gouvernement y est
sensible et engagée sur cette question
le gouvernement a rétabli et tout
récemment le droit de vote de tous les
majeurs sous tutelle et prévoit la
production par les candidats de
profession de foi en langage dit facile
à lire et à comprendre pour les
élections présidentielles je sais que
cette préoccupation est très largement
partagée par votre assemblée nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir notamment à
l'occasion de l'examen de l'amendement
de monsieur muller la participation la
plus large possible elle passe aussi par
plusieurs mesures ambitieuses qui
figurent dans ce projet de loi organique
c'est la déterritorialisation du vote
par procuration qui sera appliqué pour
la première fois dans notre pays lors de
ce scrutin avant d'être généralisé comme
prévu à l'ensemble des élections
s'appuyant sur le répertoire électoral
unique pleinement opérationnel à compter
du 1er janvier 2009 en deux elle
permettra d'y recourir beaucoup plus
facilement sans rien enlever à
l'impératif de sécurité en la matière je
voudrais rappeler à ce sujet qu en outre
nos concitoyens pourront également
profiter du dispositif déployé en ce
moment par le ministère de l'intérieur
de i procuration qui dématérialise
l'essentiel de la procédure de demande
et de transmission en mairie des
procurations la participation la plus
large possible
c'est enfin permettre aux détenus le
vote par correspondance qui aura lieu
pour la première fois pour un scrutin
présidentiel
après le succès de l'expérimentation qui
a été content
pour les élections européennes ces
avancées l'assemblée nationale les a
validés à l'unanimité et elles ont reçu
l'accord de la commission des lois de
votre assemblée et j'espère qu'elles
recevront ce soir laval de votre
hémicycle au delà toutes les innovations
les discussions parlementaires à
l'occasion de l'examen des différents
projets de loi ont confirmé l'intérêt de
toutes les formations politiques sur la
question des nouvelles modalités de vote
à cet égard je tiens à saluer ce soir la
très grande qualité des travaux de la
mission d'information consacrée à cette
question
présidée à part le président buffet qui
a rendu ses conclusions au mois de
descendre de ces travaux comme de
nombreuses contributions reçues par le
gouvernement il ressort à la fois une
attente et de ce que je qualifierais
d'une forme de retenue prudente
une attente de propositions nouvelles et
une forme d'impatience sur ces sujets et
en même temps la conscience que les
modalités qui s'éloigne de l'urne
traditionnelle et du vote papier pose
bien sûr des questions de principe des
questions de faisabilité technique des
questions de sécurité qui mérite tout
d'être évidemment étudié et soupesé
avant d'être retenu ainsi que vous
l'indiqué vous même aucune des options
dites classiques aujourd'hui dans ce
fichier ne pourrait être pleinement
satisfaisante
le vote à distance par exemple n'est ni
sur ni fiable en l'état en tout cas pas
à l'échelle nationale le vote
électronique n'est pour sa part
techniquement pas possible et nous
convenons par ailleurs tous que le vote
personnel dit à l'urne et le plus
souhaitable
face à cette situation et soucieux
d'apporter une réponse à cette attente à
ces demandes de modernisation le
gouvernement a cherché à vous proposer
une troisième voie qui nous semblent
concilier l'ensemble des contraintes
un dispositif qui puisse à la fois
simplifiée et renforcer la participation
tout en assurant un vote personnel et en
vote secret respectueux de la sincérité
global du scrutin
un mot d'abord sur le choix du texte
pour porter à cette proposition
les textes de report ne permettait pas à
l'évidence d'envisager des innovations
et nos concitoyens n'auraient pas
compris au delà des mesures d'adaptation
au contexte sanitaire des changements
dans les modalités de vote
en revanche
le texte que nous décidons ce soir de
discuter constitue cette occasion
favorable
d'abord parce qu'il porte sur une
élection certes structurantes mais
extrêmement simple dans son principe
quelques candidats départager dans une
circonscription unique par l'ensemble
des électeurs s'est elle mieux qu'
aucune autre qui se prête à la mise en
place d'un dispositif nouveau
contrairement aux scrutins
territorialisée dont les variables sont
plus nombreuses et qui rentrent izard
deux le recours à des solutions non
encore éprouvé
ensuite parce qu'il s'agisse d'une
élection qui mobilise pour laquelle les
français seront heureux que les
modalités de vote soit facilité pour
leur permettre d'y participer le plus
largement possible
le dispositif que nous porterons vous le
savez vise à offrir la possibilité aux
électeurs et aux électrices qui le
souhaitent de voter sur une machine
électronique
quelques jours avant le scrutin
présidentiel ce dispositif très innovant
j'en conviens bien volontiers jce
fondamentalement à tenir l'équilibré
cette ligne de crête très bien et ce qui
s'est d'ailleurs par votre mission
d'information cette proposition elle est
motivée par le souci de porter un
dispositif qui répondent à l'attenté
exprimée par les élus de la nation de
tous niveaux et de toutes sensibilités
politiques et qui dans le même temps
soit respectueux des principes et des
exigences qui régissent l'organisation
de nos élections
je ne doute pas que cette proposition
comme l'ensemble du texte qui sera
adoptée examiné en tout cas ce soir sera
l'occasion d'un de ces débats de haute
tenue et profondément républicain qui
honore votre assemblée
je vous en remercie merci la parole est
à monsieur stéphane le rudulier
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de législation du
suffrage universel du règlement et
d'administration générale et pour dix
minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président la
commission des lois mais mes chers
collègues on m'avait dit que ce projet
de loin en examen devant notre assemblée
aujourd'hui ne devait être qu'un simple
toilettage technique de la loi organique
du 6 novembre 1962 qui fixe notamment et
vous l'avez dit madame
la ministre les règles de l'élection du
président de la république ce toilettage
d'ambition certes limité a eu lieu
depuis 1988 un an avant l'échéance afin
d'adapter les règles de cette élection
majeure pour notre système démocratique
aux évolutions de notre droit électoral
pour sécuriser la campagne électorale et
les opérations de vote sans pour autant
en bouleverser la philosophie et son
organisation
c'est d'ailleurs ce que la commission
cet atlas heures en proposant notamment
quelques avancées significatives mais
toujours en respectant l'esprit initial
de la loi organique
ainsi la commission a adopté le fait de
renvoyer un décret simple en lieu et
place d'un décret en conseil des
ministres s'agissant de la convocation
des électeurs afin de préserver l'esprit
de l'article 7 de la constitution
la commission a également créé une
obligation pour les instituts de sondage
de publier leurs marges d'erreur
un autre point saillant de nos
discussions nous avons tenté de traiter
la problématique du chevauchement des
comptes de contente puisque le report
des élections départementales et
régionales en juin 2021 a provoqué ce
chevauchement entre les périodes de
financement de ces élections et celles
relatives à l'élection du président de
la république
aussi afin d'éviter un certain nombre de
difficultés sur la ventilation entre des
dépenses engagées par un éventuel même
candidat aux élections
ronald et aux élections présidentielles
la commission a proposé par sagesse de
ramener au 1er juillet 2021 le début de
la période de financement des élections
présidentielles alors madame la ministre
j'avais prévu de rentrer dans le détail
de ces avancées techniques mais
malheureusement un événement est venu
contrarier
mon raisonnement cet événement c'est le
dépôt ce mardi à 11 heures d'un
amendement de dernière minute par lé
gouvernement proposant la possibilité
d'un vote par anticipation par le biais
de machines à voter et cet amendement
est devenue en quelques heures un
véritable point de friction entre le
gouvernement et notre assemblée
ce qui m'amène à formuler plusieurs
observations
d'abord sur la forme de cet amendement
en premier lieu si l'intention est
louable de s'interroger sur l'évolution
et la pluralité des modalités de vote
pour essayer d'enrayer la montée
régulière de l'abstention la méthode
employée par le gouvernement paraît
quelque peu surprenante car au-delà 17
aucune saisine préalable du conseil
quand conseil d'état n'était fait
quand on change les règles du jeu d'un
mode de scrutin aussi essentiel pour
notre vie démocratique
il faut avant tout avoir l'objectif
d'obtenir un consensus de la classe
politique et de l'ensemble de la classe
politique ce qui n'est pas le cas en
l'espèce
en second lieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'amendement souffre d'incomplétude
laissant beaucoup de questions en
suspens quel serait le nombre de
machines à voter disponibles afin
d'assurer un maillage territorial
satisfaisant quelle serait la date du
scrutin anticipé
il est vrai que l'amendement que vous
proposez indique qu'il ne s'agira que
d'une seule journée dans la semaine
précédant le scrutin
mais c'est largement insuffisant et ce
n'est pas au pouvoir réglementaire de
répondre à ces questions il y avait
véritablement un risque d' incompétence
négative très élevé mais au delà de la
forme
j'en viens maintenant au fond
l'amendement et notamment sur le vote
par anticipation par définition un vote
par anticipation signifie que la
campagne officielle ne sera pas terminée
au moment où certains électeurs
accompliront leur devoir civique
or si un événement marquant venait à
bouleverser au dernier instant la
formation du jugement de l'électeur je
pense notamment au débat entre les deux
tours
les lecteurs ne pourra pas revenir sur
son vote
ainsi plus la période d'anticipation
sera importante plus le risque et le
changement d'opinion sera élevé d'autant
plus que et vous le savez la formation
du jugement des électeurs peut
intervenir très tardivement dans le
cadre du processus électoral parfois
même dans les dernières heures
malheureusement ce vote par anticipation
ne tient pas compte de cette réalité
d'un point de vue constitutionnel
j'aimerais ajouter que le fait que les
électeurs ne disposent pas des mêmes
éléments d'information le jour de
l'élection entraîne inévitablement une
rue
sur d'égalité des électeurs face au
scrutin ce qui peut porter atteinte à la
sincérité du scrutin et donc in fine et
à la légitimité du candidat élu et ceci
est d'autant plus vrai lorsque l'écart
de voix entre les deux candidats est
minime par définition le vote par
procuration est diffus car les électeurs
ne sont pas confrontés au même instant
électorale ce qui m'amène à penser que
cette disposition peut être
véritablement fragile
constitutionnellement mais permettez moi
d'évoquer le deuxième élément de fond la
problématique des machines à voter qui
si nous avons bien compris serait le
support choisi pour pratiquer ce vote
par anticipation
c'est quand même une réapparition
quelque peu surprenante de ce dispositif
qui comme vous le savez est pourtant
soumis depuis 2008 à un moratoire
le conseil constitutionnel juge de
l'élection présidentielle avait
d'ailleurs souligné dans une de ses
décisions que l' usage de ces machines à
voter soulève un vrai problème de
fiabilité liées notamment à
l'impossibilité de réaliser les tests
permettant de vérifier le bon
fonctionnement
le moratoire pour l'heure n'est
d'ailleurs toujours pas levée la
question est donc toujours en suspens et
concerne aujourd'hui près de 64 communes
qui sont équipés avec du matériel de
plus en plus vieillissant et qui se
refuse à investir sans avoir la
certitude de la pérennisation du système
j'ajoute un dernier point que l'absence
de bulletins de vote papier empêche tour
au comptage et qu'il faudra donc faire
confiance aux informaticiens pour
s'assurer de l'absence d'un quelconque
piratage on peut enfin émettre des
doutes sur le fait que le dépouillement
et lieu
le jour même du scrutin ce qui implique
que les machines à voter seront stockés
dans les mairies pendant plusieurs jours
avec le résultat des votes en mémoire ce
qui peut ouvrir la porte à des fraudes
alors juste en guise de conclusion un
dernier mot enfin sur les effets
sociologique de cet amendement on peut
se demander légitimement si cette
procédure ne favorise pas le vote des
électeurs urbains de catégories
socioprofessionnelles supérieures
ceux là même qui pourront se permettre
de prendre une demi journée de rtt en
pleine semaine pour se rendre dans l'un
des rares bureaux de vote du territoire
avant tout simplement de partir en
villégiature
le week end alors même si nous devons
nous interroger sur les évolutions des
modalités des opérations de vote
il est certain que cela ne saurait être
la seule réponse à l'abstention
grandissante car s
le mode d'organisation du scrutin qui
crée d'abstention non inconstestablement
non je pense que le désamour de nos
concitoyens par rapport à la politique
est beaucoup plus profond alors madame
la ministre
pour toutes ces raisons la commission a
émis un avis défavorable certainement à
une très large majorité d'ailleurs et ce
débat sur les modalités de vote auraient
mérité une véritable discussion
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
merci beaucoup madame la ministre mes
chers collègues ce texte met à jour des
dispositions techniques et propose de
nouveaux dispositifs pour les prochaines
élections présidentielles certaines
adaptations ne soulève pas notre
opposition
par contre d'autres nous interroge il en
est ainsi des conditions de vote des
détenus qui mériterait d'être précisée
pour d'autres nous n'y sommes pas
favorables comme la déterritorialisation
de l'établissement des procurations
notre interrogation est renforcée par le
dépôt de l'amendement gouvernemental sur
l'instauration d'une procédure de vote
par anticipation sur lequel je
reviendrai
ces deux points remettent en cause selon
nous une forme citoyenne de
l'organisation de ce scrutin
essentielle toutefois c'est ce qui n'est
pas dans ce projet de loi l'élection
présidentielle est la clé de voûte des
institutions de la vème république vous
avez monsieur le rapporteur rappelé que
l'élection présidentielle au suffrage
universel direct donne des pouvoirs très
fort et très singulier au président de
la république chef de l'état
vous avez également rappelé comme
comment depuis vingt ans la
présidentialisation je dirais moi même
il perd présidentialisation s'est
renforcée nous assumons la dénonciation
d'une pratique monarchique du pouvoir et
d'un dévoiement des institutions
républicaines qui rappelons le se fonde
sur la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de 1789
cette présidentialisation vous
l'indiquez monsieur le rapporteur chute
accélérée par l'instauration du
quinquennat et l'inversion du calendrier
électoral la dérive que nous vivons
aujourd'hui exige de rendre au parlement
son pouvoir et de le replacer comme
pivot de la démocratie cela exige donc
de revenir aussi vite que possible sur
l'inversion du calendrier cela exige de
revenir sur la durée du mandat du
président de la république
cela exige d'ouvrir le débat sur les
prérogatives de ce dernier la crise
sanitaire nous le voyons bien avec la
captation du pouvoir par l'exécutif
accélère l'exigence d'une révision en
profondeur de nos institutions
oui nous estimons qu'il faut changer de
constitution par l'avènement d'une vième
république
le texte très technique et lutte des
questions essentielles nous posons pas
bois d'amendements la question de
l'audiovisuel dans la campagne
électorale officielles et non
officielles en proposant de revenir au
choix de l'égalité durant la période
entre le dépôt de candidature et de
démarrage de la campagne officielle
ces semaines sont essentiels pour la
détermination du vote les candidats
doivent être traitées sur un pied
d'égalité et non pas sur la base d'un
critère d'équité aux contours incertains
qui intègre en particulier les sondages
qui rappelons le sont diligentées par
des instituts aux mains de grands
groupes privés peu enclin à la
neutralité dans le débat politique
les sondages doivent être encadré limité
voire interdit durant une certaine
période
nous le voyons bien dès à présent plus
d'un an avant l'élection sérieux
certaine force
faut déjà l'impasse sur le premier tour
ce sera un duel macron le pen point
barre la messe serait ainsi déjà dit et
le pluralisme et tout fait le système
américain lui-même montre bien que la
bipolarisation de la vie politique tue
la démocratie à petit feu la question de
l'argent dans les campagnes
présidentielles ni abordés que par un
biais lointain dans ce texte elle voit
pourtant être posée clairement pour
favoriser ce pluralisme si nécessaire
pour favoriser l'égalité des
candidatures il faut limiter le niveau
des dépenses électorales
nous proposerons de les abaisser
significativement
nous proposerons également d'abaisser le
seuil de remboursement des frais de
campagne vous le constater ces trois
thématiques parmi d'autres comme celle
qui viendra en débat sur les parades
parrainages sont fondamentales enfin
nous proposons qu'une réflexion soit
engagée sur les conditions de
déroulement d'une campagne
présidentielle dans les mois qui
précèdent le scrutin
le risque le risque existe qu'au moins à
l'automne nous ne soyons malheureusement
pas sorti de l'épidémie même si nous
l'espérons toutes et tous comment
permettre à ceux qui n'ont pas au moins
accès aux médias de mener leur campagne
durant une telle période
il faudra par exemple réfléchir à
élargir le temps d'antenne longtemps
avant la campagne officielle ou créer
une plateforme numérique pour ouvrir
dans l'égalité les nécessaires moyens
technologiques à tous l'abstention ne se
combattre a pas de surcroît durant une
crise sanitaire pas des évolutions voire
des manipulations techniques comme le
propose au gouvernement par un
amendement trip qui créerait le droit de
voter de manière anticipée
notre groupe est d'ailleurs comme une
majorité de nos collègues indignés
choqué tant sur la forme que sur le fond
par la méthode du gouvernement
méprisante et par cette volonté
permanente de remettre en cause la
démocratie citoyenne par des artifices
de modernité je rejoint ainsi les propos
de monsieur le rapporteur
l'abstention ne le lâchent sociaux se
réduira par le débat par la démocratie
justement par la conviction que le vote
et d'utile
nous ne voterons pas
ce texte mais nous nous abstiendrons car
il est trop limité pour répondre à
l'urgence d'un sursaut des mots claquent
et madame la présidente madame ministre
mais mes chers collègues en 1959 le
juriste georges burdeau se demandait où
était incarné le pouvoir dans la
constitution de la vème république et il
concluait tout simplement que ce pouvoir
ce pouvoir d'état était incarné donc
président de la république au titre de
l'article 5 de notre constitution qui
lui donne la capacité d'arbitrage au
sein des institutions et ça veut dire
tout simplement que l'élection de 1962
n'a pas été un changement de nature mais
un changement 2 degrés par rapport au
pouvoir donner au président de la
république avait un virage
institutionnels et c'est ce qui fait que
nous nous retrouvons là aujourd'hui
tout simplement parce que l'élection du
président de la république ne figure pas
dans le code électoral d'où cet exercice
ritualisé que nous avons tous les cinq
ans la vraie question c'est faut-il
continuer à procéder à ce rituel un
moment où nous sommes dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles
c'est ce que propose la majorité
sénatoriale c'est ce que proposait
l'exécutif avant son harding de mardi
dernier
en réalité même un texte technique reste
un texte politique et persister à le
traiter comme un texte technique c'est
simplement procéder d'une révérence trop
forte vis-à-vis de l'élection du
président au suffrage universel
cela voudrait dire aussi que tous les
autres scrutins ne serait pas important
sauf celui-là sera voudrais dire aussi
que la sacralisation de l'élection
présidentielle ne nous permet pas de
procéder à une modernisation de celle ci
or je pense qu'il faut se garder des
idoles parce que justement en adoptant
cette attitude on en vient à
intérioriser l'importance définitive de
cette élection
alors le texte qui nous a été proposé
initialement
c'est un texte de réglages
sans ambition majeure une actualisation
nécessaires avant chaque scrutin parce
qu'il faut faire un renvoi au code
électoral parce qu'il faut prendre en
compte les observations du conseil
constitutionnel le texte nous amène
quelques modifications je ne vais pas
les reprendre l ont largement été
évoquée
il y a aussi quelques ajouts de la
commission des lois la convocation des
électeurs par décret simple
l'actualisation de la liste des parrains
le caractère expérimental de la
dématérialisation des comptes de
campagne et des reçus dont l'obligation
de publication des marges d'erreur par
les instituts de sondage sur un
amendement de jean pierre sueur et le
démarrage de la période de financement
des élections présidentielles au 1er
juillet qui rétablit une disposition
contestée par le conseil d'état et nous
avons donc fait un amendement de
suppression
nous avons également fait quelques
propositions sur le parrainage en
actualisant celui ci et en donnant une
nouvelle place aux citoyens
donc cette modalité de sélection des
candidats en voulant publier la liste
des candidats par le conseil
constitutionnel en voulons faire en
sorte que les campagnes sont plus
transparents dans leur financement
viennent enfin les modalités de vote
alors je ne vais pas trop les détails et
parce que ça fait plusieurs mois que je
m'attache à le faire mais pour le faire
simplement on va dire que nous avons
tout essayé
le vote par correspondance en 2022
le vote par correspondance par
expérimentation le vote par
correspondance en 2027
nous avons aussi tenté de mettre en
place un vote par anticipation non pas
au sens où l'entend le gouvernement mais
en étant dans la période de vote au
vendredi samedi dimanche
je regrette que la majorité sénatoriale
n'est pas jugé utile de retenir
ces suggestions ou au moins de montrer
qu'elle avait une quelconque volonté en
la matière on laisse aux amandes ans
parce que dans ces cas là il ne faut pas
s'étonner
au final des initiatives qui sont prises
par les autres cantons a refusé d'en
prendre soi-même
je précise pour finir au gouvernement
qui semble découvrir en séparant des
habits de la modernité par une
suggestion qu'il est précurseur en la
matière que cela fait des mois d'un
segment que nous ne comptons plus le
nombre d'amendements pour moderniser
notre droit électoral et arrive
l'amendement du gouvernement qui a un
avantage c'est de faire l'unanimité
contre lui
comment tu es une bonne idée potentiel
eh bien je vais vous donner une réponse
comme ça sur la méthode
cet amendement est tellement bon qu'il
n'a ni besoin d'étude d'impact ni besoin
de d'un avis du conseil d'état ni de
concertation pour le coup le
gouvernement a été vraiment en marche
contre sa majorité à l'assemblée
nationale les délais ne laisse aucune
place à la réflexion pas d analyse pas
d' expertise il est vrai que la force
immanence de la force immanente part de
ce gouvernement est tellement forte que
il n'en a pas besoin bien entendu la
maman tombe du ciel dans toute sa
verticalité jupitérienne en catimini à
l'issue de la navette parlementaire bref
c'est parfait sur le fond nous avons le
sentiment d'une improvisation d'un grand
flou et quand c'est flou vous connaissez
la suite
l'amendement est structurellement
défectueux il modifie la question de
l'anticipation la question de la
territorialisation et l'extension du
recours aux machines à voter sur
l'anticipation du vote
la date est arrêtée par décret on est
tranquille excite à nouveau les
parlementaires sur la détérioriation ça
a déjà été dit
quelles sont les modalités de mise à
jour des listes d'émargement en ce qui
concerne le double vote
est ce que il faudrait en fait aidé un
électorat mobile bien intégrés
socialement c'est raymond regard sur
l'extension du recours aux machines à
voter ça a déjà été dit le moratoire
serait levé nous ne sommes pas au
courant
sur quelle base le rapport que le
gouvernement devait avoir dans le
précédent texte sur les départementales
et les régionales deux jours plus tard
n'a plus d'intérêt bien entendu qu'elle
maillage territorial
quelle est la capacité
d'approvisionnement qui paye les
machines
est ce que le seul le maire et sa le
responsable bref c'est vraiment parfait
sur la technique des machines à voter en
tant que tel il y a eu de multiples
travaux en la matière et il ya une
certitude il y a un rapport du hacking
village de dieu 2019 qui met l'accent
sur le fait qu' aucune machine à voter
aucune machine à voter n'est sûr qu'elle
soit en raison ou pas dès que l'on peut
avoir accès à cette machine il y a un
doute et l'ensemble l'ensemble des
observateurs en la matière même les
spécialistes nous disent que s'agissant
du vote
il faut être pardonnez moi l'expression
en bon français los teques c'est à dire
une enveloppe et un bulletin
alors quelles sont les intentions
réelles du gouvernement pourquoi ce
changement de pied
j'ai eu des indices en lisant la presse
comme vous le porte parole du
gouvernement nous a expliqué qu'à manuel
macro candidats avaient pris l'eau
l'engagement pardon de donner plus de
possibilités aux français de participer
tout le monde a bien compris que quand
on parlait de ça on parlait bien entendu
du vote par anticipation par machine à
voter c'était évident il n'y avait pas
besoin de sous titres c'est en tout cas
la traduction que gérald darmanin à fait
aux rapporteurs le même gérald darmanin
qui nous juré la main sur le coeur que
en dehors du vote à l'urne
il n'y avait pas de salut si cet
engagement était aussi important
pourquoi avoir balayé l'ensemble des
propositions d'un revers de la main
en fait on aurait droit là une volonté
et de moderniser le droit électoral et
d'anticiper stéphane ces journées qui a
la particularité d'être conseiller
spécial du président et eurodéputé alarm
nous explique doctement que le sujet
c'est la modernisation de notre
démocratie
christophe cartonnait castaner le
responsable de la majorité écrasé dont
je parlais tout à l'heure nous explique
que la proposition au sens où on
l'entend serait effectivement une
réponse au contexte au contexte
sanitaire leur gouvernement est en train
de se rendre compte après un an qu'il
faut adapter le droit électoral c'est
parfait l'intention mes chers collègues
c'est un piège grossesse c'est grotesque
c'est vrai mais grossier aussi pour le
cdh a le même christophe castaner nous
déclare qu' on peut rester nostalgique
surtout ne changeons rien le sénat nous
a habitués régulièrement à cela soit
mais une observation les propositions
elles viennent de cet herbicide depuis
neuf mois et non pas entre deux lectures
et en catimini en définitive et on le
sait bien
cet amendement n'a pas vocation à
aboutir la vraie difficulté c'est que
les français retiendront de cette
séquence inopportune le sentiment d'un
trait d'un tripatouillage politique même
si ce n'était pas vraiment l'intention
je regarde l'apathie du groupe et l'eire
qui n'a pas pu porter des évolutions du
droit électoral
et je dis juste que en l'espèce au vu de
ce texte nous nous contenterons de nous
abstenir
sur celui ci et sur cette mauvaise
initiative du gouvernement je vous
remercie
l'amendement numéro de 32 qui est
présente et donc par le gouvernement et
à vous madame la ministre anne merci
madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs avant
de partager avec vous l'argumentaire du
gouvernement qui a l'honneur que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter pour vous
présenter cet amendement je voudrais
d'abord rappeler le contexte parce que
je sais à quel point la présentation de
cet amendement par le gouvernement a pu
étonner voire susciter la colère
plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont dit hier
lors des débats dans les médias et l'on
dit également aujourd'hui lors de vos
propos liminaire donc je voudrais très
simplement et en toute sincérité partagé
plusieurs éléments avec vous d'abord
vous dire que je comprends votre
étonnement sur la méthode votre
étonnement votre colère même sont
légitimes
c'est vrai que nous avons déposé cet
amendement entre l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat c'est vrai que de tradition
c'est quelque chose que l'on des gîtes
habituellement de faire en sorte d'avoir
cet amendement qui arrivent ici en
discussion au sénat sans avoir pu être
examiné à l'assemblée nationale
mais je voudrais tout simplement
partager avec vous le fait que nous
travaillons pour moderniser le vote que
beaucoup d'appels ont été faits d'appel
du pied à la fois de la part des députés
mais également des sénateurs sur les
questions modernisation du vote les
amendements d'ailleurs que nous venons d
tu dis pour certains en sont la
démonstration est donc notre volonté
c'était à la fois bien de répondre à
l'engagement du programme du président
la république sur la numérisation et la
modernisation de la démocratie de
répondre à la volonté d'un certain
nombre de parlementaires de pouvoir
modernisés numériser le vote et faire en
sorte qu'en 2022 on puisse élargir les
conditions d'accès à la démocratie tout
en respectant les impératifs à la fois
les impératifs sanitaires mais aussi les
impératifs de sécurité et de sincérité
du scrutin et donc nous avons pris
effectivement cette initiative
travailler avec les services du
ministère de l'intérieur et je remercie
monsieur le sénateur philippe bas
d'avoir salué la qualité empirique du
travail mené par les services de ce
ministère et par ses administrations
habituellement et c'est ce qui nous
conduit aujourd'hui à vous proposer
cet amendement qui nous semble être une
forme de troisième voie entre le fait de
ne pas bouger et laisser à
l'organisation du scrutin telle qu'elle
est d'une part et d'autre part une
modernisation qui parfois nous sont
peut-être allés trop loin ou ne pas
permettre de garantir la sincérité du
scrutin voilà en tout cas ce qui nous a
amenés à déposer 7
et à faire en sorte de vous proposer
d'en discuter d'un évidemment le sénat
et le parlement dans son ensemble c'est
à la fois une chambre de débat mais
c'est aussi une jambe de décision et
donc évidemment c'est vous qui
voteraient et bien évidemment comme vous
le savez mais je le redis parce qu'on a
parlé de passage en force et c'est nous
le plaçons rien en force nous proposons
cet amendement est le mot de la fin d'un
évidemment il vous appartient pour en
revenir maintenant c'est la démocratie
absolument monsieur le sénateur et c'est
heureux que ce soit comme ça
pour en revenir à la présentation de
l'amendement je voudrais vous dire que
les élections donc à sont organisés vous
le savez une grande rigueur grâce à la
participation active des maires des
équipes communales de l'administration
de l'état et cette rigueur elle se
traduit par des modalités de vote simple
et efficace
un vote à l'aide d'un bulletin dans une
enveloppe dans une urne le dimanche du
scrutin via une machine cette simplicité
elle permet de réduire drastiquement les
malfaçons les fraudes les polémiques les
contentieux l égide de faire peser une
incertitude sur les opérations
électorales et sur les résultats et elle
permet de maintenir la confiance des
citoyens dans les opérations électorales
maintenant si cette simplicité des
opérations de vote elle a les avantages
de sa robustesse
elle en a bien évidemment aussi les
défauts je pense ici notamment à la
question de l'abstention qui est
importante au niveau des élections
présidentielles même si elle l'est bien
moins
cela a été notée j'y souscris évidemment
elle est moins importante que pour
d'autres élections mais néanmoins je
crois que régulièrement le procès des
élections avec une forte un fort taux
d'abstention et fait donc chacun ici
conviendra que nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire pour nous qui justement
aimons la démocratie de s'auto important
d'abstention à l'élection présidentielle
alors bien évidemment la méfiance de
l'ensemble des citoyens français elle a
des ressorts divers et variés s'il a été
abordé mais je voudrais poser la
question du nombre d'électeurs qui
auraient besoin de voter à un autre
endroit que là où il se trouve qu'ils ne
sont pas dans leur commune quelques
jours avant le scrutin ou même le jour
du scrutin en tant que tel alors
évidemment il ya des solutions qui
existent déjà je pense à la question la
possibilité de procuration je voudrais
rappeler ici que le ministère de
l'intérieur est en train de moderniser
considérablement l'établissement de ces
procurations pour les élections de juin
prochain il sera par exemple possible
d'établir une procuration avec une
nouvelle
les procédures que nous avons mise en
place partiellement dématérialisée cette
procédure elle va être plus simple plus
rapide pour les lecteurs plus sécurisé
aussi et plus allégée pour les policiers
les gendarmes et pour les mères et ça je
crois que c'est fondamental en termes de
temps et d'engagement pour autant que
ces procurations elle ne se suffisent
pas à elles mêmes
il ya certains électeurs qui ne peuvent
pas et j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure où
d'autres qui ne souhaitent pas confier
une procuration la question du secret du
vote vous le savez mieux que personne
c'est une garantie constitutionnelle au
coeur de la démocratie
et comment nous pouvons alors exigé de
la part de ses électeurs de confier leur
vote à d'autres de façon empirique pour
toutes ces raisons il nous semble
indispensable d'entamer la modernisation
des opérations électorales du pays c'est
pourquoi cet amendement il ouvre la voie
à une nouvelle modalité de vote
doublement original et facilitatrice
puisque les lecteurs pourra voter dans
une commune de son choix jusqu'à une
semaine précédant le scrutin
évidemment pour des raisons techniques
et pour sécuriser les procédures il ne
sera pas possible de voter en tout lieu
et à toute date c'est bien l'objet de
cet amendement pour autant ce que nous
voulons proposer c'est que les électeurs
puissent choisir une commune de leur
choix parmi celles qui leur seront
proposées et le gouvernement veillera à
ce qu'il y ait un maillage complet du
territoire national
certaines villes étrangères pourront
aussi être choisi et à une date fixée
par décret durant la semaine précédant
le scrutin au maximum les électeurs
pourront se rendre dans le bureau de
vote ouverts pour voter par anticipation
à ce moment-là ce bureau il sera
largement similaire au bureau où nous
nous rendons le dimanche
à ceci près qu'ils seront nécessairement
équipé d'une machine à voter puisque si
le dépouillement a eu lieu à l'issue des
opérations de vote cela serait
susceptible d'influencer les autres
électeurs et la d'interférer avec la
campagne électorale comme cela été
soulevée silure n'était conservée
pendant plusieurs jours les risques de
fraude étaient trop élevées par
conséquent les électeurs voteront sur
cette machine qui sera ensuite
verrouillé mis sous clé avant que le
dépouillement et lieu le dimanche soir
je voudrais dire que nous considérons
que cette nouvelle modalité elle est
équilibrée puisqu'elle ou des
possibilités de vote inédite sans
atténuer la robustesse du système
électoral
elle sera d'abord proposée à une échelle
zone à bhl avant de pouvoir être étendue
davantage je voudrais ensuite si vous me
le permettez et si j'ai encore une
minute madame la présidente répondre
peut-être à quelques questions qui ont
été posées à cet égard notamment dans
vos propos dans vos propos pardon
liminaire vous avez évoqué la question
de savoir combien de temps de combien de
temps les électeurs disposerait pour
pouvoir procéder à ce vote numérisés
dans un autre territoire je vous le
disais nous proposerons que ce soit
jusqu'à une semaine avant et nous
proposerons que les dates soient
réduites au maximum
eu égard aux possibilités techniques et
prises par décret vous me posez la
question de savoir quel serait le
maillage nous nous sommes en mesure à
l'heure actuelle de développer une
machine par département et je voudrais
rappeler que le conseil constitutionnel
va obligatoirement contrôler le projet
de loi organique et se prononcer sur la
conformité de ce projet loin en réponse
à la question qui était posée sur la
constitutionnalité de cet amendement en
ce qui concerne les réticences sur les
machines à voter
je voudrais rappeler que jusqu'à présent
aucun incident n'a été signalé depuis
aucune élection nulle part en france n'a
jamais été annulée pour cause d'incident
sur une machine à voter
il me semble que c'est important ensuite
je crois qu'il ya peut-être une petite
caricature qui est faite sur cette
proposition j'entendais certains dire
bah on veut permettre à des gens de
partir en vacances à la baule et de
voter quand même moi je sais c'est pas
du tout l'objet de cet amendement moi je
souscris complètement au fait que le
vote cet endroit mais c'est surtout en
deux voir et que quand on doit se rendre
disponible pour exercer son devoir de
citoyen évidemment on se rend disponible
pour exercer son devoir de citoyen mais
je voudrais dire que cette proposition
de vote numérique puisqu'il s'agit bien
de vote numéro est pas à proprement
parler d'un vote par anticipation se
veut tout numérique il favorise
notamment le vote des gens isolés qui
n'ont personne à qui confier leur
procuration ou des gens qui travaillent
le dimanche
des jeunes ou de ceux qui viennent de
déménager
enfin pour répondre à la question de qui
va payer qui est une question importante
que je ne néglige pas eh bien nous nous
proposons dans cet amendement que ce
soit l'état qui prennent en charge ces
machines pour respecter les prérogatives
qui était celle notamment du moratoire
de 2008 sur les machines et pour ne pas
imposer de coûts supplémentaires
aux communes voilà la proposition que
nous formulons enfin je dois répondre
parce que les grands auteurs ont été
cités stéphane séjourné christophe
castaner et gérald darmanin et en ce qui
concerne le ministre de l'intérieur je
dois rappeler qu'il s'est prononcé
contre le vote par correspondance parce
qu'il ya c'est vrai un risque de
manipulation et de pression et nous
partageons cet avis au gouvernement mais
pas contre le vote numérique qui permet
à chacun d'être dans un isoloir devant
une machine à voter comme lorsqu'il est
seul devant une urne dans les mêmes
conditions exactes et stricte que devant
le scrutin voilà l'amendement que nous
soumettons à votre débat ya vos voix
merci la parole est à la commission je
suis rapporteur votre avis merci madame
la présidente
j'ai déjà dans la discussion générale
défendu le raisonnement de la commission
par rapport à cet amendement
j'y reviendrai mais puisqu'on a eu
madame le ministre une transmission de
pensée vous parler de deux grands
auteurs effectivement donc je me suis
par u2 castaner mais également de
monsieur monsieur darmana donc je j'ai
pendant cette nuit
recherchez les déclarations de monsieur
darmanin est effectivement en novembre
dernier
vous avez raison le ministre de
l'intérieur a déclaré je cite ce jeu
vous les guillemets nous ne sommes pas
capables d'être sûr que le vente par
correspondance fectivement vous avez
raison comme le scrutin électronique
soit entièrement incontestable des cas
de fraudes peuvent être relevés il
écrivait également nous n'avons pas
besoin de cela
au moment où la légitimité des élus est
attaqué pire il renchéri par rapport au
vote par anticipation
contrairement aux américains les
français ont l'habitude que l'élection
se tienne en une journée
et par ailleurs il ne m'a pas semblé que
le système électoral américain soit des
plus incontestable ou plus visible que
le nôtre je m'interroge d'ailleurs sur
les volontés d'américaniser
notre système institutionnel voilà en
fait les déclarations que je tiens à
disposition de madame la ministre
mais j'aurai revenir également sur les
machines à voter et plus
particulièrement les machines à voter
qui sont déjà présentes dans notre
commune dans no 64 communes cc des
systèmes d'exploitation date de 1995
ils sont sous le système d'exploitation
windows 95
vous imaginez bien qu'en termes de
maintenance
ça pose de réelles difficultés pour ces
communes qui monte chaînes comme ils
peuvent
ce système mais qui n'ont pas de réponse
effective de la part de l'êta depuis
2008 et ce qui est d'autant plus
surprenant c'est ce que je disais dans
mon propos c'est que on a balayé d'un
revers de main ces difficultés notamment
l'interrogation sur la fiabilité de ces
machines à voter c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui donnera sa décision
de 2008 indiquent qu'il y avait un
problème de fiabilité notamment dans le
cadre des élections législatives de 2007
et puis sur le dernier point sur le vote
par anticipation et je jouerai
simplement dire la chose suivante
faudrait pas abouti à un moment donné à
des opérations de vote à l'identique que
une commande sur amazon
je sais que ça peut être signe de
modernité mais je pense que puisque vous
citiez de grands auteurs je vous renvoie
à l'esprit des lois de montesquieu qui
disait la chose suivante que l'isolant a
été essentielle pour la suspension du
jugement
quelques instants afin de faire le bon
choix et c'est pas d'être rétrograde que
de penser que notre système électoral
actuel est quand même le mieux adapté
pour notre système démocratique c'est la
raison pour laquelle la commission et
pour toutes ces raisons que j'ai
évoquées
préalablement émettra un avis
défavorable merci je vais donner la
parole à monsieur paco pour explication
de vote
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
rapportant dans le ministre je
reviendrai pas sur les circonstances
étonnante de l'arrivée de cet amendement
et vous avez vous même madame la
ministre reconnu effectivement que il
c'était un petit peu cavalier entre
guillemets ou baroque
j'ai trois choses moi simplement à vous
dire d'abord en ce qui concerne la
motivation de cet amendement il ya un
objet généralement il ya un objet
lorsqu'on rédige des amendements vous
avez prononcé quinze fois au moins le
mot modernisation mais en fait il semble
que la véritable intention ce soit la
lutte contre l'abstention
c'est souhaitable c'est louable
simplement je suis très étonné je n'ai
pas vu une seule fois le mot lutte
contre l'abstention enfin l'expression
donc dans votre texte
et cet objet il est très bizarre l'objet
d'un amendement il est à pour expliquer
pourquoi il ya l'amendement là vous
n'expliquez pas pourquoi vous expliquer
comment c'est une suite en quelque sorte
votre objet il complète entre guillemets
un amendement très incomplet que vous
avez d'ailleurs complété dans vos
explications
vous m'avez fait la leçon tout à l'heure
sur l'égalité à juste titre peut-être
mais alors moi je vais vous la faire
parce que franchement en matière
d'égalité d'accès aux bureaux de vote
électronique
alors là vous allez pouvoir m'expliquer
vous allez devoir m'expliquer j'habite
dans un département qui s'appelle l'oise
c'est un grand rectangle
alors on ne sait pas combien il y aura
de bureaux de vote il y en aura un
visiblement c'est même pas dans le dans
l'objet ce sera dans le décret alors
comment sera-t-il choisi on peut
supposer que ce sera la ville préfecture
à moins que ce soit une ville où la
république en marché fait bon vote
je n'ose le croire toujours est il que
si c'est dans l'oise 6,7 à beauvais
quand vous habitez à noyon à
crépy-en-valois aux confins de laine
très cher présidente aux confins de la
seine et marne vous êtes à 100 km de la
ville centre 100 km aller retour ça fait
200 km pensez vous que
beaucoup de gens notamment les ruraux
vont faire la route vous allez
privilégier donc certains urbain les
ruraux ils ont l'habitude d'être méprisé
mais il commence à en avoir assez
n'oubliez pas les gilets jaunes est
alors en matière de bilan carbone pour
un gouvernement qui nous donne des
leçons d'écologie quotidiennement alors
là bravo
la dernière chose pour terminer et je
reprend l'idée de notre rapporteur
effectivement la citoyenneté c'est un
droit c'est un devoir
c'est même une chance c'est une
responsabilité
il a parlé d' amazon monsieur leur
d'ailier il a tout à fait raison
moi je vous dirais que je ne souhaite
pas que notre démocratie devienne en
fait qu'elle lève se concertèrent
collègues j'ai fini qui se consomme je
ne veux pas d'une phase où 10 à sion de
notre des moments acides
merci monsieur queiros madame ministre
d'abord je dois vous féliciter pour
votre humour et votre audace parce qu'il
en faut il en faut pour présenter un tel
amendement
je ne sais pas comment on vous dit il ya
un concept qui doit être propre à la
république en marche ça doit être la
creuse études
quand on regarde cette proposition elle
n'est tout simplement pas sérieuse
quelques points simplement factuel on va
pas revenir sur la je pense qu'il faut
pas revenir sur la méthode parce que
nous sommes à peu près tous au courant
de la façon dont les choses se sont
passées et j'allais dire c'est une
habitude pour le gouvernement de passer
en force sur le parlement quels qu'ils
soient sur sa majorité également mais
simplement rentrons dans la rentrée dans
la technique
il ya plein de problèmes à problèmes
tout simple celui de la
déterritorialisation du vote
le fait que pour la première fois avec
cette proposition avec cette proposition
de vote anticipé il n'y aurait plus
moyen de rattacher un électeur
à sa commune puisque en effet celui-ci
voteraient dans un bureau distincts et
donc en fait nous n'aurions plus pour la
première fois de connexion entre les
lecteurs et son territoire et ça peut
éventuellement faut c'est la façon de
concevoir les concevoir les le sens des
votes sur l'orientation sociologique
vous dites qu'il n'y en a pas ce faux et
on a un bon exemple c'est tout
simplement le fait que en ce qui
concerne les procurations
elles ne sont pas utilisées socialement
de la même façon
et en effet c'est souvent la population
la plus insérés et la plus mobile qui en
profite et on aura exactement la même
possibilité dans le système que vous
proposez par ailleurs quant au principe
d'égalité vous nous disiez andrade dans
tous les départements très bien sauf
cela revient à considérer que tous les
départements sont égaux du point de vue
démographique ce qui est forcément faux
au delà des problèmes de au-delà des
problèmes de déplacement
et puis il y a singulièrement la
question des machines à voter
et là il faut être clair tous les ans il
y à des études de fait sur ses machines
à voter
la dernière étude c'est celle du
discount village de 2019 je vous les
citer tout à l'heure aucune de ces
machines ne peut être certifié conforme
quoi qu'il arrive des moments il y à une
intermédiation entre le vote et celui
qui utilise cette machine à voter il y a
un problème
ce problème vous ne pouvez pas le lever
cet amendement est une fausse bonne idée
c'est de la poudre aux yeux et vous
voulez nous faire passer pour des
ringards en ayant eu cette idée parce
que nous allons la repousser d'une
certaine façon ce soir j'en suis assez
fier
merci monsieur tu es mal si on la
présente je reviendrai pas comme mes
collègues mais je crois que mon a
compris sur les conditions d'intégration
à deux tentatives d'intégration cet
amendement je crois que tout le monde a
dit ce qu'il va dire moi ce que je
regrette c'est que si vous avez eu cette
idée là je suppose qu'elle n'est pas
arrivée maintenant mais on aurait pu
imaginer qu'à l'issue des élections
municipales où chacun a pu noter les 10
q tu es rencontrés et que chaque lot
même temps ils nous on devait tous
vivent dorénavant aucun virus etc
peut-être qu'il aurait été intéressant
d'ailleurs que le lisent intérieur
réunissent les parlementaires les chefs
de partis pour imaginer des dispositions
particulières plutôt que de venir là
avec cette cette fausse bonne idée
et pour pas être trop long juste aussi
dire que moi je qu'une fois sur le vote
par anticipation contrairement à
d'autres je pense cette idée
intéressante et pour moi il ne s'agit
pas d'être de marie camille reine des
dalits alors on va dire sur le chemin
des amis à car je pense que c'est une
vraie question qu'on peut se poser comme
d'autres questions d'ailleurs
sereinement sur comment on peut
poursuivre en tout cas faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait plus de participation au
scrutin
je pense c'est une question qu'on doit
se poser en tant qu' en tant que
parlementaire et je crois que celle ci
comme d'autres on doit pas avoir de
tabou mais pour autant je
malheureusement peut-être train de tuer
cette idée dire que parce que ce qui va
ressortir ce soir c'est que la romance à
rejeter et que c est là sera enterrée
pour très longtemps donc c'est vraiment
un vrai sujet dernièrement aussi sur la
modernité
vous avez ce mot à la bouche il faut
numériser la démocratie je sais pas très
bien ce que ça veut dire
moi ça m'inquiète et mais par contre dès
qu'on pose d'autres options d'ailleurs
on l'a vu dans les précédemment toutes
été rejetées
donc attention madame la ministre à ne
pas faire de communication ce soir qui
serait j'ai voulu moderniser et le sénat
cette chambre rétrograde a voulu nous
bloquer je crois que ce ne serait là
aussi pas un jeu dire un une bonne chose
de faite en démocratie donc ce soir je
crois que le moment sera projeté et je
vous invite à un peu de sérénité et de
hauteur de vue je vais pas partager le
tir de barrage de mes collègues sur le
vote anticipé
et puisqu'on parlait de bilan carbone
c'est pas la peine d'aller jusqu'aux
états unis pour observer cette pratique
puisqu'elle est pratiqué depuis des
dizaines d'années en allemagne et en
version papier avec des modalités
sécurisé et ça fonctionne y compris
quand les écarts de scores sont très
serrés on ne remet pas en cause le mode
de scrutin à cause du vote anticipé donc
on aurait pu envisager une forme de
modernisation moi je pense aussi que ça
aurait pu être envisagée ici en france
malheureusement vous l'avez adossé aux
machines à voter qui elles sont plutôt
un retour en arrière dans l'aude en eau
nos pratiques démocratiques puisque si
nous avons des urnes transparentes
c'est bien pour une raison que nous
n'accepterions pas que nous passions à
des urnes opaque dans nos bureaux de
vote
les machines à voter reviennent en gros
à fermer complètement la transparence du
scrutin et pose un problème démocratique
certains je pense que les machines à
voter actuellement en utilisation en
france devrait démonter envoyer au
recyclage elles me servent elles sont
dangereuses pour notre démocratie
je pense qu'on devrait pas avoir à voter
à travers ces dispositifs lors d'un
dispositif simple et transparent on
devrait le garder
par contre le vote anticipé pu être
débattue autres mois de façon plus
apaisée
s'il n'avait pas été aussi si vous êtes
vous n'aviez pas été aussi cavalier avec
cet amendement
merci messieurs opère madame la ministre
sur cet amendement j'y verrais une
motivation vertueuse celle de combattre
l'abstention mais pour faire diminuer
l'abstention il ya deux moyens soit en
donne les moyens aux électeurs aux
citoyens d'aller aux urnes parce que
c'est ce que vous proposez mais les
citoyens qui veulent voter le peuvent
il ya le rituel de l'élection le rituel
de l'isoloir comme ça at il dit et les
procurations
deuxièmement il faut surtout donner aux
français l'envié d'aller voter et pour
donner envie d'aller voter il faut
donner le choix et et lors des dernières
élections en particulier les élections
européennes
le fameux moi ou le chaos ça casse et
l'envié d'aller voter
merci denis benarrosh madame la ministre
je ne voudrais pas être désagréable en
fait je voudrais pas être désagréable
mais mais en fait je crois pas il ya les
pros vise à sion hasardeuse de votre
mesure ni un travail acharné de dernière
mesure au répondant à l'appel de toute
hâte à 2
deux parlementaires qui aurait fait que
vous auriez abouti sur cette solution un
peu trop tard mais suffisamment tôt pour
faire nous l'a présenté ici en
catastrophe je n'y crois pas du tout je
suis désolé j'ai plutôt une
interprétation un peu machiavélique
excusez moi mais machiavélique au sens
de machiavel est au soc littéraire pas
au sens péjoratif du terme
et c'est quoi cette interprétation je la
vois pas avec trois questions la
première qu'est ce qui va se passer si
votre abonnement est refusé je suis
désolé chers collègues s'étaient mal je
pense que les éléments de langage sont
déjà prêts le fait de dire que c'était
la modernité et que face à la modernité
il ya tout
comment dire tout un ensemble d'élus du
peuple qui se sont opposés à cette
modernité parce que ça aurait trop gras
des deux veulent pas cette modernité je
pense que les éléments de langage dans
la présentation même qui en a été faite
par des votes du gouvernement depuis
deux jours sont déjà en place donc je
pense qu'on va y avoir droit
et si par extraordinaire quelque chose
avait fait que l ait des chances de
réussir et que cet abat deux mois soit
passé quels étaient les buts visés en
fait
réfléchissant quel est le public visé
calais l'électorat visée on l'a déjà dit
on connaît qu'elle ait l'électorat qui
va se déplacer qui va chercher quel est
le bureau de vote où il peut aller
qui va prendre véhicule qui va faire des
placements qui va aller voter dans une
machine à voter sans bulletins de vote
et sans avoir reçu dix les professions
de foi ni aucun élément supplémentaire
qui lui permettent de faire le vote
auquel il est habitué
c'est sûrement un short un électorat qui
est déjà motivé pour ce type de foi de
vote qui va être motivé par cette
élection qui est un électorat qui
sociologiquement et déjà un peu marqué
et dernière question la date
une semaine avant certes mais qui valent
à décider la date serait d'abord c'est
le gouvernement en fonction de quoi dans
le décret en fonction de quoi en
fonction d'un calendrier qui doit lui
même choisi de son côté y compris le
calendrier dans un événement de campagne
y compris dans un débat alors oui si
j'étais machiavélique je dirais que
c'est un gagnant gagnant pour le
gouvernement
gagnant gagnant et un perdant qui est la
démocratie merci même la présidente
assassi merci madame
la présidente et merci à madame la
ministre pour la défense de votre
amendement qui a été relativement longue
la ministre gouverner c'est prévoir et
si votre ambition est vraiment de
moderniser enfin la modernisation
je crois sincèrement sans être moi aussi
machiavélique que vous auriez anticipé
le débo le dépôt de cet amendement je
crois que vous ne pouvez pas laisser à
penser que d'un seul coup une idée a
jailli d'un esprit très brillant qui
s'est dit mince on a oublié de le mettre
dans le projet de loi organique et c'est
donc on va le déposer en catimini est là
haut au sénat je suis d'autant plus
méfiant que cet amendement arrive au
moment même où des débats anime des
formations politiques sur des
modifications des scrutins de
différentes élections
donc il est à l'ail sorte de cohérence
qui à mon avis n'est pas le fruit le
fruit du hasard alors sur le fond nous
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire dans la
discussion générale tous toutes les
raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
opposés à cet amendement est bien
évidemment nous votre compte mais madame
la ministre sur la lutte contre
l'abstention
alors sincèrement et honnêtement je ne
crois pas un instant que cet amendement
pourra remédier à ce terrible fléau
telle abstention dans les quartiers
populaires je suis une élue de la
seine-saint-denis dans les quartiers
populaires mais pas que mais je ne
voudrais pas stigmatiser les quartiers
populaires l'abstention est très forte
et vous le savez très bien on ne cesse
de le répéter ce n'est pas par des
artifices techniques mécaniques pour
répondra à cette envie parce que les
gens ont envie de participer au débat
politique
ils ont envie des changes la vie est
tellement compliqué qu'ils ont envie de
savoir les raisons pour lesquelles nous
sommes dans une situation économique
catastrophique et pas que
à cause de la crise du coc vide ils ont
envie de partager
ils ont envie de construire ces gens et
donc je vous le dis sincèrement non
seulement cet amendement ne répond pas à
l'abstention de façon générale mais
surtout madame la ministre vous ne fait
pas rêver les gens avec ce genre de
proposition merci monsieur bonnecarrère
dont nous ne voulons pas renouveler les
termes de la discussion générale
quelques observations rapide sir étions
l'objectif du gouvernement lorsqu'il a
déposé mardi se faire de ma part ou
mercredi en début de matinée son
amendement
à l'occasion de l'examen du texte il l'a
déposée exactement 2 je pense que c'est
mardi de manière concomitante à
l'adoption du texte qui concernait la
date des élections départementales et
régionales
ce qui veut dire que si effectivement le
gouvernement avait l'objectif de
favoriser la participation est
d'imaginer un autre mode électoral à 24
heures ou 48 heures près je suppose
qu'il avait quand même réfléchi puis
quelques jours de voir depuis quelques
semaines ason hypothèse de travail
il avait toute possibilité de demander
d'ouvrir cette possibilité à l'aco
l'occasion des élections départementales
et régionales d'être dans une logique
d'expérimentation ce qui pouvait se
comprendre et ne nous mettez pas en
risque par rapport à l'élection
principal de notre démocratie
deuxième élément machines à voter
puisque à les deux éléments anticipation
machines à voter
la notion de la chine a voté aujourd'hui
vous n'en avez pas degrés sur notre
territoire
donc soit madame la ministre
vous avez
disposer de ceux de cet équipement très
bien si ce n'est pas le cas vous nous
parlez d'une machine à voter qui a
développé
vous comprenez bien qu'il n'est quand
même pas très convenable d'organiser un
mode de scrutin présidentiel à partir
d'un outil dont nous disposons pas
aujourd'hui et qui seraient à envisager
à développer trop troisième observation
sur le terrain de la modernisation
nous avons regardé ces sujets et nous
avons été très étonnés de voir que les
pays qui paraissait le plus en pointe
dans cette modernisation je pense en
particulier à l'estonie qui maintient sa
position mais qui est un pays plus
modestes mais je pense surtout aux pays
bas et à la république fédérale
allemande était revenu en arrière par
rapport à l'utilisation des mécanismes
électronique
je suppose quand même que vous avez fait
une étude européenne là dessus et
j'ajoute enfin que la référence au
portugal est assez curieuse et j'en
termine puisque le portugal procède par
votre par anticipation que je n'ai pas
du tout connaissance qu'ils utilisent la
une machine électronique dont je
comprends pas très bien pourquoi cette
référence vient dans notre débat et vous
renouvelle l'enjeu de maintenir la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans le
processus électoral
si monsieur le comte merci madame la
présidente madame lis mes chers
collègues il faut oser mal de tout bon
faisait après une année où nous a
expliqué qu'on ne pouvait pas changer
les règles où nous faisons des
propositions et à chaque fois c'était
non on pouvait pas modifier les règles
électorales et était immuable tda vous
avez rappelé le rapporteur les paroles
du ministre de l'intérieur
fille d'un seul coup voilà alors qu'un
texte venait d'être adoptée pour les
élections départementales et régionales
on ose et on ose proposer à un
bouleversement complet sur plusieurs
points en même temps on aurait pu
parler des machines à voter on aurait pu
parler du vote anticipé finalement ce
sont deux sujets et ben non on ose et on
est tous en même temps
alors que pendant un an on n'a fait que
de l'immobilisme c'est quand même assez
étonnant
faut oser alors oui la question de
l'anticipation allocution d'anticipation
il existe une fait les français de
l'étranger le fond lorsqu'il vote par
internet
donc c'est pas nouveau dans notre
procédure électorale
on aurait pu aller un peu plus loin mais
pourquoi madame la ministre vous nous
proposez tout ensemble
pourquoi madame la ministre le
gouvernement nous propose aussi des
machines à voter alors que vous l'avez
évoqué il ya quand même beaucoup de
réserve qui s'expriment dessus pourquoi
ne pas avoir proposé
finalement dans un seul auteur de
principe de précaution mais c'est vrai
que quand on ose tout principe de
précaution de le faire pour les
élections départementales ou régionales
sur un département ou une région donnée
et qui souhaitent le faire
enfin il ya une question d'égalité ça a
été évoqué quant à plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres pour aller à la machine à
voter
qu'on ne dise pas que c'est ça sera
facile pour tout le monde et pour ceux
qui travaillent quand même l'orientation
qu'on nous avait donné et je pense aussi
puisque s'agit vous vous l'évoquez aussi
pour les français qui vivent hors de
france là c'est pas des centaines c'est
des milliers de kilomètres qui séparent
ont les français de cette machine à
voter
donc voilà pour toutes ces raisons ça
semble assez étonnant cette proposition
décalé par rapport à un texte qui quand
même à vocation à traiter de problèmes
sérieux avec des arguments sérieux
merci monsieur président hockey si un
mari et sa collègue
et oui je crois qu'on est tous d'accord
sur un point technique et conrad calcium
et qu'on a tous raison mais on n'est pas
opposé par principe à une modification
par vote par anticipation les machines à
voter
je suis un peu réticent mais pourquoi
par jour et par contre ce que je pense
c'est que il faut faire des
expérimentations
quand on change les règles du football
aux yeux
lui vaut un simple arrêt de jeu eh bien
il ya les tournois juniors et les
compétitions en bandoulière jouer ou en
l'expérimentent on essaye
eh bien je pense qu'il faut pas
expérimenter sa régulation prudentielle
qui est le top 14 régions
donc on commence par des scrutins d'être
cantonné aux interdépartementaux rien
n'est pas trop tôt ou régionaux mais
quand est ce qu'on doit rouler ce
système
et puis on verra après pour l'élection
reine et qui est que rien
ainsi monsieur caistab à madame la
ministre vous avez revendiqué la
modernisation comme étant la motivation
du gouvernement
qu'est ce que c'est que votre
modernisation est ce que c'est être
moderne que de réformer les conditions
du scrutin présidentiel sans aucune
délibération de l'assemblée nationale
sans aucune possibilité pour l'assemblée
nationale de modifier le texte du
gouvernement
belle modernisation est-ce que c'est
moderne de modifier substantiellement le
code électoral sans prendre l'avis du
conseil d'état
est-ce que c'est moderne madame la
ministre de présenter un tel amendement
qui concerne l'organisation de notre vie
politique sans avoir pris la précaution
d'une concertation avec l'ensemble des
forces politiques de ce pays
est-ce que c'est moderne de réformer
l'organisation des bureaux de vote sans
demander leur avis aux représentants des
maires
est-ce que c'est moderne madame la
ministre de présenter au parlement
dans ces conditions aujourd'hui au sénat
un amendement qui ne règle pas toutes
les questions fondamentales que pose la
réforme que vous mettez en oeuvre au
point qu'on peut se demander
s'il ne serait pas frapper comme les
juristes e10 d' incompétence négative
vous voulez les mains libres comme
d'habitude vous voulez tout réglé par
décret comme d'habitude vous arrivez
avec un texte qui est plein de lacunes
de failles qui n'a pas été étudiée
sérieusement
alors là je dis si c'est ça votre
modernité alors je suis obligé de vous
dire je préfère me ranger parmi les
anciens que parmi ces modernes là et je
vais ajouter une chose vous allez jeter
la suspicion sur la sincérité du vote
vous allez faire voter des français
alors que la campagne présidentielle est
en passe d'atteindre son pic dans les
deux ou trois derniers jours de la
campagne des électeurs qui n'auront pas
tout vu et qui se seront quand même
prononcé
vous allez mettre en place une
organisation qui est une vraie usine à
gaz et dont on entrevoit que les
prémices et puis le résultat tout ceci
c'est je voulais sûr si vous persévérez
la contestation de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 comme trump a
contesté celle des états unis en 2021
mais si monsieur ça va j'ai dit oui mais
merci madame la présidente mme amhis mes
chers collègues qq deux petits mots un
mot une question le mot c'est sur la dtt
ruralisation vous avez eu du mal à le
dire d'autre si s'ils sont bien plus
éloquents et comme vous
franchement on n'a pas besoin
d'affaiblir la commune on n'a pas besoin
d'affaiblir les relations entre les
maires et l'état
donc je pense que c'est une mauvaise
chose dans la confiance qui doit être
établi entre l'état et la commune la
question je vais vous poser madame la
ministre je vous ai écouté vous avez
fait une défense d'amendements assez
argumenter avec des fois d'été sont
enthousiastes puis des fois plutôt des
freins parce que vous avez bien senti la
difficulté quand même de nous convaincre
je vous ai écouté pendant neuf minutes
je me suis dit il va y avoir une
ouverture elle va nous dire ce qui est
valable pour la présidentielle est
valable pour les législatives
comment ça se fait que vous avez oubliez
ça vous avez oublié l'assemblée
nationale c'est à toute votre
argumentation sur l'abstention sûr il
faut des thériault lisez etc
vous avez des législatives qui sont dans
la foulée des présidentielles on élit
les députés après on va élire les
sénateurs et sénatrices et là hop il ya
un brouillard total donc franchement ça
sent l'opération politicienne on en a
peut-être pas vu encore le loup mais ça
ressemble à ça parce que sinon vous
auriez intégré quand même au minimum
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat dans
votre réforme c'est aussi une façon
quand même de manquer de respect au
parlementarisme
mais si vous pouvez me répondre ça
serait bien madame la ministre pourquoi
vous avez omis de parler des listes
hâtives on a droit de s'abstenir liste
hâtives alors à s'abstenir au
départemental on l'aura de s'abstenir
aux régionales on a droit de s'abstenir
au municipal
mais la part par un vent terrible
il faudrait alors là se sont rués vers
la présidentielle
vous sentez que l'abstention va reculer
comme ça mais si monsieur président
marseillais
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission madame la
ministre
moi je serai un peu moins sévère que
beaucoup de nos collègues qui se sont
exprimés parce que malheureusement je
pense que cet amendement vient
d'ailleurs et que le gouvernement a pris
en même temps que nous son existence et
donc je rends hommage au ministre qui a
dû s'est évertué à défendre quelque
chose qui était pas très défendable
pour autant c'est malheureusement le
rôle du ministre
je pense que nous vivons malheureusement
une démocratie sous ordonnance depuis
près d'un an
les circonstances sont très
particulières c'est vrai mais elles
deviennent de plus en plus particulière
sur le plan démocratique
aujourd'hui on est obligés tous les
jours de s'interroger pour savoir si les
élections seront maintenus alors date
que dira le conseil scientifique
on est obligé de lire les ppl qui
surgissent à l'assemblée pour savoir si
le mode de scrutin aux élections
législatives sera le même ou s'il sera
proportionnelle on est obligé de
regarder
jour après jour si comme aux municipales
on a le droit d'avoir de procuration ou
malheureusement parce que le
gouvernement ne le veut plus qu'on ne
les aura pas pour les départementales et
les régionales parce que pardon si on
peut pas aller voter
il ya les procurations on n'est pas
obligé d'aller faire quelques kilomètres
pour aller voter de voir une improbable
machine je ne sais où
dans un département et puis on est
obligé de se pencher régulièrement pour
savoir si les conditions de votation si
les jours de votation si les campagnes
seront celles que nous connaissons aussi
elles vont évoluer
je pense qu'il faut mettre un terme à
tout cela je ne parle même plus de ce
qu'on avait évoqué dans un passé pas si
lointain
la baisse du nombre de parlementaires ou
le redécoupage des circonscriptions
je pense que notre démocratie a besoin
de stabilité
elle a besoin de stabilité et notre
démocratie est malade et les manades et
nous avons un devoir collectif
quand je vois le résultat de certains
sondages qui nous promettent des choses
que nous ne souhaitons pas
quand je vois ce qui se passe dans une
grande démocratie au capitole jeudi
qu'il faut vraiment que nous ayons un
sursaut est que nous ayons la volonté
collective de faire en sorte rapidement
de stabiliser la situation et d'avoir
une démocratie stabiliser c'est le moins
qu'on puisse faire vis-à-vis des
électeurs si on veut qu'il vient de
voter merci je voulais je voudrais vous
simplement vous signaler pour pour que
vous puissiez vous organisez que nous
aurons un scrutin public et monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez demandé la parole
est ensuite viendrait par le président
oui madame la présidente je vais essayer
de convaincre madame la ministre du bien
fondé de notre position vous avez admis
que la forme n'y était pas mais
j'aimerais revenir maintenant cieux sur
le fond madame la sénatrice a évoqué la
crise sanitaire on espère tous quand
même qu'en avril et mai 2022
la crise sanitaire soit derrière nous je
pense que l'ensemble des sénateurs de
cet ensemble et partagent cet avis mais
imaginons un seul instant que la crise
sanitaire soit toujours aussi active en
2022 dans le procédé que vous nous
proposez vous ne pouvez pas anticipé le
nombre d'électeurs qui arriverait dans
ce bureau de vote
imaginons que votre proposition soit
retenu est un sentiment d'un bon nombre
de français vous pouvez vous pourriez
avoir des centaines voire des milliers
d'électeurs qui convergent vers un même
poids et créer un
un spot donc dire que c'est aussi une
réponse à la crise sanitaire moi je
prendrais un peu plus de précautions
monsieur
notre collègue philippe val a rappelé
c'est pas la première fois que les
élections présidentielles ont lieu
durant durant les vacances scolaires
donc j'étais recherché en fait les taux
de participation sur 2017 et et 2007
et on s'aperçoit que le premier tour du
scrutin de 2010 7 a eu lieu pendant les
vacances scolaires de la zone à c'était
lyon bordeaux et classe et de la zone dé
marseille strasbourg lille etc et que le
taux de participation a pourtant atteint
77,5 17%
il en est de même pour pour 2007 et
enfin juste pour conclure il ya eu des
recours aux procurations qui ont déjà
été facilitée notamment 3,36 millions de
personnes ont voté par procuration lors
de l'élection présidentielle de 2017
ça a été dit en 2022 le recours aux
procurations sera facilité d'autant plus
avec l'article 71 du code électoral qui
dispose que désormais tout électeur peut
sur demande
exercer sa procuration et puis également
ça a été dit là des territorialisation
du vote
je me pose la question pourquoi ne pas
avoir souhaité par exemple prolonger le
dispositif de double procuration pour
l'élection présidentielle voilà madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur vif et la
présidente de la ministre chaque
collègue moi j'ai quelques observations
je veux pas revenir sur tout ce qui a
été expliqué tout ce qui a été dit à la
fois sur le fond et sur la forme sur la
méthode
naturellement nous partageons ces
analyses mais le sénat au mois de
décembre dernier a commis un rapport en
tous les cas la commission des lois sur
le vote à distance vous avez eu la
gentillesse et la sympathie de le
rappeler tout à l'heure en tribune
nous avons auditionné un grand nombre de
personnes singulièrement un grand nombre
de services y compris naturellement des
services de l'état et ya au moins deux
points de convergence qui ont été
partagées par tout le monde
c'est l'insécurité techniques et
juridiques du vote par internet
à ce jour 20 numérique à ce jour et de
l'utilisation des machines à voter c'est
le point sur lequel tout le monde s'est
accordé à dire sur tout n'y allez pas en
tous les cas pour le vote numérique n'y
allez pas maintenant gouvernement de
vision d'ailleurs les services
gouvernement disant nous ne sommes pas
encore prêts nous travaillons avant sont
peut-être dans quelques années mais ne
sommes pas prêts pour l'instant mais
c'est véritablement ça faisait consensus
auprès de tout le monde
dans ces conditions là les choses
étaient claires
le directeur de l'anssi qui s'exprimait
devant un parlementaire d'un député
récemment moins d'un mois le 18 janvier
dernier sauf erreur de ma part si je dis
pas de bêtises vient de confirmer
clairement qu'il était hostile à
l'utilisation des machines à voter
compte tenu à la fois de leur
obsolescence naturellement et du risque
de cyberattaques un moment où nous
sommes encore là en ce moment un hôpital
de département du rhône est victime de
cyberattaques
il se fait plusieurs fois que les choses
arrivent on imagine bien que ces
machines à voter qui porterait en leur
sein le langage le vote d'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens
trois jours avant le dimanche du vote
pour être elle même faire l'objet de ce
type d'attaquants tous les cas d'une
insécurité totale
on ne comprend pas en réalité on ne
comprend pas que aujourd'hui on puisse
nous proposer ce type de solution alors
même que de notoriété publique
ce moyen de vote et contesté de façon
extrêmement larges et extrêmement
consensuelle
c'est surtout ça que nous voulons vous
dire on peut toujours imaginer vouloir
envisager d'autres moyens de vote des
évolutions après tout pourquoi pas mais
la condition substantielle
c'est la sécurité absolue
hélas nous ne l'avons pas c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons eu
un avis extrêmement défavorable pour ne
pas dire autre chose
madame la ministre merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vais tenter de répondre à
plusieurs des questions qui ont été
posées lors de vos interventions d'abord
j'observe dans les différentes
interventions des uns et des autres que
l'objectif que nous voulons défendre par
le biais de cet amendement il me semble
être partagé et faire consensus celui de
lutter contre l'absence moi de faire en
sorte que chacun et chacune puisse venir
participer davantage à l'élection
présidentielle nous partageons
l'objectif me semble-t-il
et c'est déjà quelque chose dont vous
nous réjouir je voudrais répondre sur la
question de la mission d'information
notamment du rapport qui est prévu par
le gouvernement sur la question des
machines à voter et répondre à cet égard
que bien sûr ce rapport sera remis comme
prévu dans les six mois suivant la
promulgation de la loi dans laquelle cet
amendement a été adopté et donc le
gouvernement va continuer son travail
son travail de présentation et de rendre
compte aux parlementaires de l'avancée
des questions des machines à voter
notamment de la question du moratoire et
tout cela sera évidemment abordé comme
c'était prévu et comme cela a été voté
dans ce rapport je voudrais bien
rappeler que nous ne sommes pas là dans
un vote par correspondance
j'ai bien écouté monsieur le rapporteur
les citations que vous avez partagé de
monsieur mise de l'intérieur il me
semble que miss de l'intérieur fait à ce
moment-là état de ces de ses réticences
et que je partage et qui sont largement
partagées vis-à-vis du vote par
correspondance je suis tout à fait
d'accord monsieur le rapporteur avec
vous sur l'importance de se trouver seul
face à son choix est seul face à son
vote
et là on sera vraiment besoin devant
union devant une machine à voter plus
précisément et donc 7,7 instants de
solitude et de suspensions avant le vote
il sera bien prévu est bien maintenue
par pas le dispositif que nous proposons
je voudrais rappeler je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure mais comme la question a de
nouveau été posée je voudrais vraiment
rappeler que tous ces achats se ferait
potentiellement aux frais de l'état
il s'agit évidemment pas d'un tweet est
une
elle dépense à des maires je voudrais
préciser également que le choix des
communes dans lesquelles ces machines
existerait serez fait si c'est un moment
de l'insurrection était en pleine
consultation avec l'ensemble des maires
pour pouvoir disposer de ces machines à
voter dans les endroits où il y aura du
monde c'est une possibilité
supplémentaire on n'oblige personne
parce que parfois j'ai entendu certaines
réflexions qui aurait pu amener à penser
que maintenant tout le monde votre et
cette manière non c'est vraiment une
possibilité supplémentaire qui est
offerte en matière de bilan carbone par
ailleurs si on veut regarder le bilan
carbone c'est une préoccupation louable
et qu'évidemment je partage nous allons
pouvoir réduire justement bilan carbone
puisque l'idée ce n'est pas que les gens
se déplacent quelque part pour avoir
accès à cette possibilité de vote c'est
que quand ils se sont déjà déplacés
ailleurs ils puissent voter en dehors de
leur commune sans avoir à faire c'est
aller retour mais oui donc très très
concrètement cet argumentaire je me
permets de le dire ne n'augmente pas à
la question du bilan carbone
je voudrais réagir sur une question de
forme et qui a été abordé par plusieurs
membres du groupe socialiste et pardon
mais c'est de le souligner mais mais
c'est le cas moi je vois bien que gêné
en dessous il ya quand même un petit
procès d'intention qui nous est fait en
disant oui vous avez déjà prévu des
éléments pour dire si et ça moi j'ai
prévu de rien dire du tout moi
personnellement je n'ai pas prévu de
m'exprimer
outre mesure sur les questions qui me
sont posées je n'ai pas de rendez vous
dans les médias dans les jours qui
viennent et dont vous nous fait un
procès d'intention d'avoir préparé des
éléments de riz pour de réponse pour
dire que le sénat est ringard moi j'ai
jamais dit que le sénat était ringard on
est toujours le regard de quelqu'un on
est toujours le moderne de quelqu'un moi
je suis venu à la politique par un
sénateur maire jean claude boulard qui
était sénateur maire du mans pour qui
j'allais plus profond respect et qui
était très engagé dans la défense du
bicamérisme et dans la défense du sénat
vous ne trouverez jamais aucun propos
méprisants de ma part j'y vis à vis du
sénat et jamais je n'ai traité qui que
ce soit de ringard ou d'anti moderne
je ne crois pas que ce soit là
débat on propose simplement des
alternatives il ya des alternatives qui
sont proposés d'ailleurs aussi par des
sénateurs sur la modernisation du vote
certaines nous avons étudié d'autres
nous les avons rejeté parce qu'elle ne
semblait pas pouvoir garantir la
sincérité du scrutin
donc il ne s'agit pas de faire une
modernisation à tout prix et une
escalade vers la modernisation ou
l'américanisation ou que sais-je
mais très simplement de proposer des
solutions qui volent et qu'ils soient et
qu'ils soient très concrète jeu madame
la présidente alsace nous dit vous ne
fait pas rêver les gens un peu
péremptoire moi je crois qu'il ya des
gens qui rêvent des gens qui ne rêve pas
là je pense qu'il ya un débat sur la
question de la participation et je pense
qu'au contraire est d'ailleurs l'intérêt
qu'ils nous avons été les premiers
surpris à voir qu'il y avait un intérêt
d'ailleurs d'une grande partie de la
population pour ce débat que nous avons
là ce soir nous montre à quel point les
citoyens sont demandeurs de nouvelles
possibilités sécurisé pour pouvoir aller
voter et donc pas de passage en force ya
une proposition notre part une
proposition un débat qui est en train
d'avoir lieu et puis un vote donc il ya
évidemment aucun passage en force et
simplement une possibilité offerte
d'aller voter ailleurs voté ailleurs ça
ne peut pas se faire le même jour de
façon sécurisée parce que nous sommes
vraiment attaché à pouvoir garantir la
sincérité du scrutin et faire en sorte
que le scrutin ne soit pas contestée moi
je suis très sensible à des arguments
qui ont été portées par plusieurs
sénateurs de dire qu'on a absolument
besoin de ne pas arriver à un scrutin
présidentiel qui serait contestée et que
cette sincérité elle est nécessaire pour
l'ensemble de la vie démocratique et là
nous sommes en mesure de proposer cette
situation qui nous semblent sécurisé
enfin pour répondre sur la question des
législatives
effectivement ce qui concerne les
élections législatives la particularité
c'est qu'il ya différentes
circonscriptions est donc là avec la
présidentielle oui là avec la
présidentielle c'est une circonscription
unique et donc il nous semble plus
laisser parler la ministre merci madame
la présidente
cela il y a vous me posez des questions
je vous répondrai pas m'entendre
reproché de vous répondront à vos
questions sinon je réponds pas aux
questions moi ça me dérange pas je suis
à votre disposition gouvernementale à
disposition du parlement et je suis
disponible aussi longtemps que
nécessaire
je disais donc sur la présidentielle il
a une circonscription unique et c'est
pourquoi ça nous apparaît c'est opportun
de faire cette proposition de pouvoir
voter en distance yale mais en étant
présente par des machines à voter pour
la présidentielle parce qu'il ya une
circonscription unique pour cette
élection et c'est la seule à cet égard
merci beaucoup merci donc j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe l'est républicain sur
l'amendement numéro 32
et je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable il va donc
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voici le scrutin le résultat du scrutin
numéro 84 sur l'amendement numéro 32
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
344 pour l'adoption 23 contre 321 le
sénat n'a pas adopté
[Musique]